[Music]
you
[Music]
awesome thanks so much gone all right
hey good hello I'm Harriet as Glen said
I'm from Melbourne Australia and today
I'm going to be talking about community
building with the help of
sociolinguistics so this talks about
what sociolinguistics
is how it's relevant to us in the
JavaScript community and how each of us
can use tactics from there and our
day-to-day communications to help make
the JavaScript community more welcoming
to everyone and a really nice thing to
be a part of before we get too deep into
that a little bit about me I work at
build Kate as a technical writer we're a
continuous integration platform so our
product is mostly used by other
developers so I spend a lot of time
thinking about how best to explain parts
of our product to technical users who
may or may not be familiar with
continuous integration I also worked as
a front-end developer for about five
years before I realized that I was
actually way more interested in writing
documentation and helping other
developers use cool tools than I was in
writing code so this realization kicked
off my master's degree and now I'm most
the way through a masters of applied
linguistics at the University of
Melbourne we're doing this degree that I
got interested in the intersection of
linguistics and computer science and
from there I started looking at language
communities and how they're built so
this talk started life as a paper for
uni especially in fact and it gave me an
opportunity to compare a tutorial that
introduced JavaScript from ten years ago
to one from 2013 it turns out that I
can't actually fish four or five
thousand words into a 25-minute talk but
I've tried my best and you're welcome to
come find me afterwards if you have any
questions so let's talk about
communities what is the community pretty
much just a bunch of people all together
doing the same thing
and in linguistics we call this a
community of practice this place where
we do shared meaning making usually this
term is used for communities they've
formed around a specific goal - like a
project or an open-source tool but we
can take this further and we can look at
communities that form around programming
languages their communities and practice
just like the ones that form around
natural languages we need to keep in
mind what our community looks like from
the outside as well as from the inside
because this is what we look like to
potential new members so when a new
person wants to join a community they
have to learn the things that we do
differently to their existing
communities so all of us here are part
of the JavaScript community and likely
you're part of a lot of other ones as
well have a think about the general
feeling that you get from people on the
internet talking about using javascript
this is talking about using Ruby this is
talking about using Soylent it's all
slightly different now all these things
that we do differently can be roughly
divided into two categories
got language and culture the language
things that's like jargon and
community-wide in-jokes and that kind of
stuff the cultural things that's our
approach to open source our diversity
strategy how we go about solving
problems problems with communication as
well as programming problems that
language can also be described as
linguistic factors and cultural ones can
be considered social factors so if we
merge these two together yes so if
you're linguistics so we've got some
definitions Sofie linguistics study of
how language functions in a society is a
really broad field and covers way too
much stuff for this talk so if something
more relevant to us is language
socialization this is how becoming a
member of society
through the use of language so I said
this talk would be about
sociolinguistics
allied it's about socialization but that
doesn't sound anywhere near as exciting
so in the natural language learning
sense socialization is all of the words
that we use and all of the other stuff
that is not words as well you might
already be familiar with this concept
have you ever found that it's easier to
learn a language if you're living in a
country that speaks it you get all the
pronunciation the slang the body
language and other important junk all at
the same time
and all of this together is
socialization so being part of a
community means that you're helping to
build it and we want nice communities we
want people to feel welcome and we want
it to be easy for them to join and these
things are really important because we
want more people to come and be part of
the JavaScript magic so let's have a
look at how we can do this better so
JavaScript people are actually already
pretty great at this stuff compared to a
lot of other tech communities but what
does socialization look like in practice
the most important thing for us is the
language that we use when we talk about
JavaScript so there are different
programming languages we have different
ways of being a member so how do we let
people know what our special JavaScript
way of doing things actually is we use
socialization strategies and there's
heaps of them and I'm not going to cover
all of them today I've picked out some
of them I've divided them up into three
categories to make them easier for us to
use so start with we've got welcoming
learner focused and community focus
strategies so there are two types of
welcoming positive and negative so an
example of some positive welcoming is a
tweet something like this here's my tiny
project learning this thing was hard
what was also fun and worth it so let's
break this down into sections here's
some of my tiny project this little bit
actually tells us quite a lot about our
community of practice it tells us that
posting a very small project or a
fragment of one is totally normal
and that things don't have to be huge
brilliant ideas and they don't need to
be finished or perfect for us to share
them learning this thing was hard this
shows people who are reading the tweet
that JavaScript developers are
comfortable with vulnerability that
makes vulnerability okay for others as
well also fun and worth it so ensure
that there's a payoff for all this work
that you're putting in and you don't
have to finish things for them to be
worthwhile sharing so these these things
together when viewed from outside the
JavaScript community welcomed people in
a positive fashion seeing tweets like
this Foster's goodwill towards our
community and could even sparked
people's interest in learning
javascript so seeing tweets like this is
great for users who are new to
JavaScript but it's also nice for people
who are already members it helps
everyone feel more comfortable about
using javascript and being associated
with our community just as a side note
it's often not possible for people in
minority groups to post things like this
they can be seen as less capable and
less experienced even if they're an
expert and it's potentially damaging to
their job opportunities so those of you
who are in positions of privilege please
use that privilege so me please to make
this communication style the norm so
next up we've got negative work Lane
I've made this full request how about
this for the footer my friend has
commented on it also gross
this might be an in-joke we both know
it's sarcasm but for anyone not in our
exclusive little sarcasm Club this looks
really mean but it's obviously a joke
right no it's not actually it makes us
look like when someone makes a pull
request we're going to attack the
quality of their contributors work make
a lot of their efforts and could be
alienating for existing team members as
well as for newcomers could even
entirely scare off potential external
contributors so negative welcoming like
this and other types of hazing confronts
new members with their shortcomings
imagine seeing this when you've only
just started using javascript and you
thought this PR looks great you're
likely to think this is what they're
saying about this code what are they
going to say about mine and that's
pretty discouraging the next up we've
got learner focused strategies let me
start off with legitimation this is
telling learners and members that the
things that they have been working on
our legitimates so be incurring to
people working in JavaScript or on a
particular project kind of like positive
reinforcement so it's hard to be in the
JavaScript community if no one
recognizes the work that you're doing as
an appropriate use of JavaScript for
example a colleague posts this pull
request updates the new sign-in page and
I've commented cool merged thumbs up
our first glance this is friendly and
supportive but what if we took this a
step further with something more like
this nice use of props you're really
getting the hang of react merged that's
up this isn't much longer but it conveys
the same message as the previous comment
but importantly it makes it so clear to
the author of the pull request that the
work they've done is a good use of the
language that they're working in you can
also use this strategy if someone has
tried a new approach to a problem that
didn't work out or a pull request that
isn't going to be merged these scenarios
should not be legitimize the work that
was done so we can make sure that the
author's still feel positive about
working with JavaScript just by changing
how we talk about it so this leads into
our next strategy normalizing failure so
failing to complete a task shouldn't
reflect on you personally or your coding
ability we all know that writing
JavaScript is hard and we're not perfect
all the time we need to also make sure
that our juniors and people outside our
community know this as well as well as
our existing members for example I've
personally been trying to stop using the
words easy and simple in documentation
that I wrote who say we have some setup
instructions my setup instructions from
my super ed project get set up with our
short and easy instructions simply spin
up a docker container
run tests run build party so we've got
both words easy and simple here and
these instructions are fine if you know
how to do all the steps and they run
smoothly but if you don't know how to
use calm or if anything goes wrong
we've already undercut our use of
confidence by telling them that they
should be finding this easy by adding a
few extra bits to these instructions we
can make people more comfortable with
not succeeding on that first shot so
let's add some more to that introduction
so the steps below will help you set up
super red project if you run into any
trouble check out our FAQ or ask a
question plaque so we've removed the
word easy which is a great stuff and by
mentioning that you may need help
we're immediately normalizing the
possibility of failing to set this up so
we can make a list of instructions
better to
spin up a docker container run test with
MA go build the code with NPM run build
hi so by removing the words simply from
the first step we've changed the
expectations about how difficult this
task is going to be and by adding links
to more information we've removed the
frankly unreasonable assumption that you
already know what you're doing and
you're not going to need to look
anything up so these two learner focus
strategies legitimation and normalizing
failure work together really well to
make it easier for all of us to
persevere when we're faced with problems
that we don't know how to solve next up
we've got self-efficacy this is about
supporting people's belief in their own
ability to succeed a study was conducted
in 2012 into first-year University
students perceptions of their own coding
abilities when they were learning how to
program the TLDR of this study is if
they didn't believe in their own ability
to succeed and to successfully write
code even if they didn't even if they
made a lot of mistakes along the way
both their performance and their mental
well-being decreased dramatically
one of the major takeaways from the
study was that if students have much
higher ratio of successes to failures
when they first learning they're much
more likely to develop resilience and
positive self-efficacy so we can take
that suggestion and apply it to our
community so when people are learning
JavaScript helps them have a good time
with it
if your project or team has new
contributors start tagging all your
tasks even if you know it's something
that you'll personally be working on so
lots of projects use tags and they're
issues they usually look something like
these here we've got an issue update
team photos to use new module the three
tags front end new contributor and get
started these tags are great and they
flag things clearly is being appropriate
for people who are starting out but I
think we can do one better what if we
were tagging with more youthful and less
junior oriented language like these
react only self contained and documented
these provide even more information for
us now also not specifically targeting
people who have
previously contributed to this project
juniors will still be able to identify
this as a task that they're capable of
and it provides all the pertinent
knowledge straight up rather than having
to wade through an issue description it
tells you that it's only react so that
you know you won't suddenly find
yourself waiting through a sea library
and adding that it's documented lets
contributors know that if they're having
a hard time there's easily accessible
help available so having put a little
bit of extra work into these tags this
issue already feels much less like a
busy work junior task which to be quite
honest I hated being assigned when I was
a junior and like the legitimate useful
work that it is it's also much more
appealing for developers at other stages
of their career as a senior developer
you don't always want to be reactive pre
architecting parts of your product or
untangling spaghetti food or shaving
acts while solving complex bugs
sometimes you need small tasks that are
well documented the last line of focus
strategy that I'm going to talk about
today is legitimate peripheral
participation and that's what I'm
particularly passionate about so it gets
rocket's so this is about ways that you
can participate in the JavaScript
community that aren't writing code but
are still important parts of being a
member things like uploading Stack
Overflow questions and answers or asking
and answering them yourself writing
blogs and medium articles tweeting about
new things that you've done or
challenges that you're facing making
these activities just as important as
writing code makes our community easier
to join and it's easier to be a part of
for existing members while writing code
is a core part of our community having
other activities be equally important is
way more fun and provides us all with
legitimate ways to engage when we can't
or don't want to be writing code so
finally we've got our community focused
strategies
firstly I'll talk about is active
participation so this is about
encouraging people to do communication
well we don't get awesome communities
without people interacting with each
other so even though this is called
active participation and covers
activities like reading blog posts or
looking at things on Stack Overflow as
well as obviously active things like
talking on other developers and
attending meetups so everyone here has
already taken a great step for this one
by attending this conference and now you
can all take it a step further so tell
the people that you meet what you're
working on even if you don't think it's
particularly exciting or if you're
willing to really commit to improving
your community tell people what you're
struggling with you might find yourself
talking to someone who has had the exact
same niche webpack config bug and can
tell you how to fix it
so next up we've got strategies for
getting help this is about defining how
people can find help relating to your
project this applies to internal
projects as well as those and source
ones so rather than just listing the
names of the maintainer x' and you'll
read me or on your project page and
assuming that people will know that they
can get in touch with you have a go at
figuring out and writing down some ways
that users or team members can get help
so we want to define as much as we can
so that people are comfortable trying to
help themselves and if that doesn't work
then they're also comfortable asking
other people for help and this can be
scary it's a bit like calling up to book
your own doctor's appointment and
talking to people on the phone it's
generally not a good time but it is
vastly improved if you know what you
should say and when you need to say it
in the same way asking for help with
JavaScript can be much less difficult if
you know that there are steps that you
can follow so let's add some more to
this readme we could add sections for
debugging so maybe different parts of
your project have different debugging
strategies like installation versus
running tests
good add an FAQ if you have community
support like flat groups or local
meetups and tell them where to ask
questions so other places that people
can go to ask questions if they can't
sort it out for themselves
so we're arts questions is really a
whole point of its own and leave me to
my final community focus strategy
support structures now these are really
vital there are so many different places
that you can get help in the JavaScript
community there are thousands of online
tutorials Meetup
Twitter conferences github issues flat
groups and so many more but we need to
let people know where to go and that
it's okay to do so so javascript already
does this pretty well we encourage
people to talk about things that have
gone badly as well as ones that have
worked but we can set an even better
example for our newcomers by posting
about things we've learned at every
level so it doesn't just have to be
junior developers writing about their
first experience with JavaScript or
senior developers talking about super
advanced and deep technical concepts
first about how you've been working with
JavaScript for five years and you set up
your first Express server the other day
or how you finally looked up exactly
what that node n o ants are actually
means so opening up the conversation
about learning at all levels creates and
defines the support structures for all
our members no matter where they are on
a javascript journey so let's recap
socialization is all the things that we
do to become members of a new community
and all the things that I've talked
about today are used all the time in
natural language learning and a really
super effective at building language
communities they're all things that we
can start using in our programming
communities so let's start thinking
about the language that we're using when
we interact with our fellow developers
when we're training new team members
when friends ask about JavaScript or
start using it for the first time and
especially when we post on the internet
about JavaScript by thinking about the
language that we use when we talk about
JavaScript each of us can make our
community a friendlier more comfortable
and more welcoming place for new people
and new ideas
[Music]